en octobre 2001 les états unis et l'otan
s'installe en afghanistan l'objectif
annoncé était celui ci mettre la main
sur les terroristes d'al-qaïda et
surtout bel laden protégé par le mollah
omar le chef des talibans mais 20 ans
après l'arrivée des américains plus de
mille milliards de dollars dépensés les
talibans arrivent au pouvoir en dix
jours à peine ils posent leurs valises
et parade fièrement dans les rues de
kaboul sous le regard dépité du monde
entier il forme même un gouvernement un
cuisant échec pour les états unis un peu
comme si cette guerre n'avait finalement
presque servi à rien derrière lui le
gendarme du monde laisse des millions
d'hommes et de femmes à la merci de
guerriers sanguinaires et qui malgré
leurs promesses ouvre la voie à divers
scénarios incertain pour l'avenir du
pays alors aujourd'hui concrètement que
reste-t-il de l'héritage américain en
afghanistan a plus grand chose si ce
n'est des armes et des chars à
l'aéroport de kaboul notamment est
triste constat pour joe biden celui qui
aime tendre et c'est l'étendard de la
démocratie et des valeurs contre les
autocraties il débute son mandat avec
cette défaite sous le feu des critiques
sur le dossier afghan joe biden a
exaspéré par son silence lorsqu'il sort
enfin de son mutisme
le président américain tente tant bien
que mal de se montrer ferme et confiant
sans vraiment parvenir à rassurer et les
images à l'aéroport de kaboul valent
mille mots on pouvait y voir le
désespoir et la panique des afghans qui
s'accrochait aux avions pour fuir le
pays et les défis sont encore nombreux
pour le locataire de la maison blanche
après de longs tentatives dans les
montagnes afghanes ou irakienne encore
une fois les états unis échouent à
importer un modèle de démocratie par les
armes dans des pays de cultures et de
traditions totalement différente et ce
n'est pas joe biden le démocrate qui
changera cette tradition américaine